for some reason I have this philosophy
that the higher my hair is on my head
the less gross it looks and the more it
attracts from my forehead scar hey guys
it is Tuesday oh it's great so it's time
to talk back to you talk back Tuesday is
that the name of this day I happened to
find it but I've been saying it so let's
do it let's start over on Twitter Oh
- Olivia 25 new person new person to
person probably they don't know when a
new person comments on any of my social
media I praise the crap love them and
welcome them to the it's grace family it
is dysfunctional and really really funky
we all smell pretty bad 0 - Olivia - 5
more like zero - I'll live with you for
25 seconds and then I won't do it
anymore because I'll find the reason for
the season
some of my windows broken
you know just binge watch 2 hours of old
grace helbig videos because I obviously
have nothing better to do the only good
binge is a youtube binge all other
binges are
not good for you unless it's like Real
Housewives or Pringles Real Housewives
are like the pickle flavored Pringles of
television shows like you look at them
in the store and you're like that's
disgusting I'm just gonna try it and
then you get home you're like oh [ __ ]
Minerva V one two three no person two
persons new person Minerva v12 three
Minerva is a Latin term for the goddess
of bears I'm gonna look that up
oh no she's the Roman goddess of wisdom
and the sponsor of the arts trade and
defence okay close to the goddess of
bears you're brave you're alive whee I'm
gonna remind myself of this tweet every
morning now let's go to top that weird
tonight two hearts and a Helbig new
person your person in person is this a
new person guys I've lost all track of
who I paste and who I haven't two hearts
and a Helbig more like two shirts and a
smell bag
poof I'm sorry she drew the Holy Trinity
maybe her grace I'll be heading out this
is pretty accurate Hannah looks a little
bit like old school Tyler Oakley mamrie
looks a little bit like great tits
great tits I'm distracted by our tits
sunshine galaxy for to person to person
to person sunshine galaxy for more like
middle 9 the Science Guy
mmm he's so fly for white guy but also
great eyes and also great thighs whoops
you haven't proved Tim brings grace for
diarrhea medicine yeah my brother in our
Boston show decided to do a bit where
you brought me diarrhea medicine on
stage for about 30 seconds so look that
up on the YouTube
the apple doesn't fall too far from the
other Apple that fell off the tree of
the apple tree now let's go to YouTube
well you get it okay Jeffrey Stephens a
new person to person to person Jeffrey
Stevens somewhere like Jeffrey's stevia
the fake version of Jeffrey Stevenson
them that's the version I'll give you
cancer you're the bride I'm so in love
with Flula join the club and then get
out of it because I want to be the only
one carrier web new person to person to
person carry web more like do turtles
have nipples just curious do only met
mammal mammal mammals have nipples from
conception until sexual differentiation
all mammalian fetuses within the know
what I don't know if this is not what
I'm into Chad Walter new person to
person to person Chad Walter more like
Chad as your collar popped I just feel
like every chad has to have a collar
popped or they die grab someone by the
head at work today it felt awkward
hopefully I don't get a sexual
harassment charge filed against me
tomorrow
only medium ly hoping for you well
that's it for talking back to you today
I hope that you enjoyed your time
because I had wonderful time I need to
shower cuz I smell like if you ever like
scraped salt on like a dogs underbelly
and then let it sit in the Sun for a
while that's what I smell like I don't
know
rhymes with Ben add a new person to
person to person rhymes with banana more
like Hannah Montana
oh no yeah I had a dream that gray stuff
like a maim time we're going to kill me
then I told them I bought camp Takota so
they didn't hatch tie cap Dakota that
listen the dream
don't forget to buy tickets to the
nofilter show in London and Dublin
information is blue